When we get this
up and running,
we gonna be outta here.
Stanford, Morehouse,
Spelman.
This is something
Einstein
spent his entire life
trying to do.
We prove that
time travel into
the past is possible,
if we just give
it some time.
You scare me,
but you inspire me.
You going places, CJ.
Since Pops is gone,
I got to make sure
that you get there.
I don’t need you always
playing big brother.
I’m the only big
brother you’ve got.
NYPD – don’t move!
Calvin Walker – a
19-year-old, black teen
was allegedly
shot and killed
by an NYPD officer.
Walker was armed with
nothing but a cellphone.
I am so sorry
about all of this.
If I could go back
and fix it, I would.
If we just go back,
get them out of there,
then he’s saved.
We only have so many
times to get this right.
Everything’s going to
need to be perfect.
What’s today’s date?
June 28th.
Woohoohoo!
Sebastian, this
has to work.
No!
We’re too late.
It’s about controlling
something we obviously
have no control over!
My brother didn’t
deserve this.
I just miss him, yo.
How many times have
you jumped back, CJ?
We’re not superheroes.
Where is the justice?
We can’t do
this anymore.
We only have
two jumps left.
Where is the justice
for our sons
and our daughters.
When will it end
for the whole nation?
You gotta listen to us,
you’re going to
get killed.
Get on the ground!
On the ground, now!
Get down!